[Music]
you have to build a brand that nobody
else can buy anywhere else if you're a
retail store in 2021
2022 and you don't have a private label
that is the number one thing you focus
on you will never win
this portion is like with me so i think
this is when you need to get selfish
like you need to ask your question
[Music]
hiring is guessing firing is knowing
like you got to go fast that's how you
get [ __ ] done that's how you figure
stuff out this
is the television
and the television is the radio
the 40s [ __ ]
we'll kind of just go around the room
one time i'll uh introduce you to some
folks and then uh we'll go through the
second time and go deep with everyone so
uh i'd like to start by introducing you
to jonathan cott who's down in australia
jonathan say hi to gary give him a
little bit of your vitals
cool hey gary how are you doing
i'm uh
hey i'm a sports scientist but i use uh
physical health to get leaders to
practice mental skills like optimism
courage grit and accountability so they
can create a work life that i love and
experience the five elements of
fulfillment so i just wanted to share
that there's a very heart-centered
mental performance the mental well-being
aspect of what i do i don't train
athletes
i love it
cheers cheers
we've also got andy richards uh dialing
in from north dakota andy say hi
hey gary pleasure being able to see you
on this i've always watched you and i
really appreciate all your work um thank
you i got my master's degree in
aerospace space studies designing human
life support systems around 2017 and i
realized i had a knack for complex
systems but it also applied to people
and i started helping companies find out
problems or
sales revenues or getting into different
markets or whatnot
and uh
one of the things that i'm kind of
looking for
the cannabis space with helping some of
the true thc companies create delta
delta 10 products to develop brands that
are national prior to their ability to
access the full national market
and then i also help with some companies
that do marketing and creating lead
funnels and whatnot and
my goal from this is to
learn how to maximize myself and have a
brand for what i can bring to companies
learn as much as i can but then also
uh kind of glean some information on how
to help the emerging markets that i'm
forging and do that i have a personal
passion for
i understand
very cool
and uh over in california we've got
bobby thompson who's in the legal space
bobby say hi to gary hey gary how you
doing man i'm well bobby how are you
good good so i have my own personal
injury wrongful death um
firm and
i'm kind of one of those guys where
nobody needs me until they need me you
know right right and um and so my i'm
not a billboard guy i'm not a volume guy
um i'm very selective in the cases i
bring on so i'm really trying to just
my my social game and then have targeted
campaigns for niche i got it cases i got
it well well yours is gonna be
i've been thinking about your space
for who knows what reason probably saw a
billboard so i'm very prepared i'll be
ready awesome thanks dude
and uh sticking in california we've got
a guy that built and sold a cafe and is
now running a content agency and i love
it robin xander robin say hi
gary so good to see you um jack of all
trades self-taught acrobat circus
performer uh started a restaurant with
no experience on three weeks notice sold
it three years later on craigslist came
here because i run a conference in the
hr space that claude spoke out in new
york in 2018.
these days run xander media mostly we're
doing explainer videos and just trying
to figure out how to scale this uh
to build an
agency where i understand
i understand i think
and uh somebody that i've really uh
thoroughly enjoyed reading all of his
e-newsletters recently lee over in
denver colorado with turbine labs lisa
gary hey gary
lee how are you good to see you man good
to see you so uh founder and ceo of
turbine labs
based just outside of denver colorado uh
founded the company several years ago on
the premise that the way that we're
getting our
news and information is completely
broken in fact it's been broken for over
a decade
our job is to fix it so we're an ai
powered executive intelligence software
platform
that dramatically reduces information
overload and media fatigue for
executives policymakers and decision
makers i like it understood hey there
thanks for having us gary
it's great to appreciate
thank you um
so back in 2005 to make it short and
sweet i started in wholesale i sold to
retail
barney's bloomies anthropology some
really big wig clientele and i always um
had a passion for fashion it was always
in like you know my dna it was always
who i was but the life you know that
todd and i live it was never something
that we were able to do on our own we
always hustled we always worked hard i
always sold software i worked for
groupon i always had side gigs but on
this you know for 10 years i built a
side business
which was an e-commerce website and it
was um designer clothes similarly to
some of you know what bloomingdale cells
or denny cells um but my
um my niche has always been customer
service based it's always been driving
um self-confidence and self-awareness
and self-esteem and all different you
know we're all created differently and
our bodies are all different but we
should all feel beautiful and look
beautiful and um i really try to hone
that in with young girls and really
build uh awareness when you start so
love that you started a um a brick and
mortar during this time where you know
stores are closing left and right and
we're really trying to set ourselves
apart in the industry and be somebody
that's here in the front runner you know
as a front runner for the long long haul
so
where is that store
right in central new jersey in manhattan
um so
we have a good market and when did you
open it
we opened the brick and mortar in
november uh this past november so it's
been a year and we've been online as
this um as this business which is called
spirit animal for
uh about four years now
and and were you able to lock in just
like a really attractive retail
situation given the reality of the world
yes we were prime space right on route 9
which is the main like we're right next
to a starbucks like right in the middle
of um of town and we got to go and are
you and are you there every day
for the most part that's you know i know
of course i know we do okay awesome
thank you
that's amazing very cool
yeah thank you thanks for having me of
course back around the room we're gonna
start with jonathan uh jonathan
you're up with gary you've got probably
about six seven minutes and then we'll
we'll move on so jonathan say hi again
and uh
what you got going on
okay sure
okay to share my religion so your
religion is day trading attention my
religion is that your physical health is
the foundation of your mental
performance and emotional well-being and
so the biggest benefit i see when i
coach ceos and leaders to live this
statement is in their self-esteem and in
their personal and professional
relationships
and so this is i'm talking to a man
who's invested in this and really
prioritized this in his company but you
can imagine who i'm selling to like i'm
saying totally
execs and group exec level is a big
business so if you were in the room how
would you sell physical mental and
emotional well-being of their people
i wouldn't
and let me explain what i mean by that i
think you have the luxury of being in a
moment in time where the conversation is
elevating and i think to your point
you're talking to somebody who's
probably further along down the path
but when you're not talking to me nine
years ago when i was like where is
everybody else you can feel everybody
coming i think for all of you
that this is something i've got to
really do a bigger job of in my content
i might even write a damn book about it
i don't think you should try to sell to
people that are unsellable
when for the majority of you
and definitely for what you're doing
um
you only have so much limited resources
with your time
so i think from a macro strategy
standpoint
you need to think about
i think one of the things you need to
think about who you want to get in front
of and vet them as much as they're
betting you i think um
you know one thing that's very wild
about
the vayner x world
is how little i try to spend time on
convincing people and to your point
similar to you we're selling something
that's different
we're going to be able to aspirate you
know so i think first and foremost
jonathan
try not to get you know convinced like i
think that there's enough people in
australia that should already know that
it's a viable conversation and i think
before i let go of this is why i'm still
talking i think you need to think about
creating a scenario
where you're
very much up front
letting them know that you're vetting
them as well because you really don't
have time to convince them
yeah so that there's two things that
said like i've i've heard your your
message about don't sell the unsellable
so if i like the person that i'm talking
to believes in my religion but then they
are someone who's ingrained in that but
then they have to go to the upper levels
of their organization that means selling
that doesn't just because you have a
rabbi or a co-signer that doesn't mean
you're not you're still
the only person that i refer to don't
sell to the unsellable is the person
writing the check yeah yeah okay fair
enough to your point it's a really good
point though
there isn't an organization that doesn't
have a jonathan cheerleader in it right
now
yeah the problem is
that's not what i'm referring to and i
think that's a huge waste of your time
potentially i'll give you another
example i think you can make money to
get customers
so
i will i i wonder if you should build a
front-facing layered virtual scalable
business that charges people two hundred
thousand jesus christ sorry two hundred
dollars for two hours
of a virtual workshop that is the
gateway and maybe i don't like that
price let me start over maybe twelve
hundred dollars for two hours in a
virtual environment that becomes the
gateway it's really the reverse of what
i tell
james and and and
joe here on the call like literally this
is not a joke and i'd love to get your
body language on this
they know that if anybody that ever does
a four d's feels that it was
a setup for a bigger engagement that
they're in deep [ __ ]
but i actually want you to build the
reverse i want you to build a business
potentially that charges a thousand
virtually because now you know they're
committed to the hypothesis yeah i think
you get a lot more business by working
that
and then using that as your leads
than just kind of doing any other
version of that that's just another
important thing for you to think about
because to your point
every company hates the company right
like every employee like every company
has employees that like think the
company doesn't get it right and so of
course they want to push this because
this is a progressive you know angle in
the scheme of things i don't think that
that's a good use of your time unless
you're paying 1200 bucks for you know
for the ability to sell it harder in
your organization otherwise you're going
to get too many run around some too much
wasted energy
yeah
and if i've got time to i just asked for
a similar question and i asked her right
so
she got it like we're developing people
but the biggest like business benefits
so the people who's looking at the
dollars and cents
uh the conversation went through like
retention that is the dollars and cents
that
this religion or looking after people is
going to have the biggest benefit of
business do you agree or do you have a
different take
i
meaning that you believe if you tell a
cfo in that environment that you have
better retention and that's why it's a
good investment do i think that lands
no not not necessarily like convincing
the cfo but just like to to actually
create the business case
like to turn this religion into a
business case like what's what's the
reason the business invests in this like
yeah yes you can get like i don't know i
think
i think i think it's not only retention
but i also think it's employee
acquisition
acquisition as well right of course
because it's a value prop that others
are bringing to a workforce that now
believes in it
yeah cool cool
all right so thank you yep we'll go
around if we have more time we can do a
little free form at the show
now you guys know if uh if i feel a
little bit despondent when we're talking
about your business it's because i'm not
trying to sell you things
i have scared joe quite a bit
like a one person ever feels that you're
in trouble let's roll over to andy uh
andy up in north dakota what you got for
us hey gary i got a couple sets of
questions that are pretty should be
fairly easy for you i have a feeling but
um
my whole life i've sprinted and pulling
and shot at everything i've ever done i
started a gym while i was in college to
be able to train executives and then i
realized that most those guys didn't eat
healthy so i created a food delivery
service that i outfitted my parents lake
home to coach the food and delivered to
them so that i got
more
videos and high level people and as my
career progressed i ended up becoming a
vp of a radiology company where i
realized there's a lot of people in
there that wanted unbiased advice and i
started doing that and as i progressed
for my career my
education i realized that every company
buys promotional and branded materials
so i started doing that so that i could
work with the marketing companies and
then also have input and giving free
additional input
and as i've worked through all this what
i've kind of realized is
there's a lot of emerging markets that
are available that a lot of companies
are able to pivot into or
i myself and now set myself up to be
able to help
career into some of those
opportunities that are coming
and with the point-and-shoot mentality
and i know that you do things very fast
uh what is your criteria when
determining emerging markets for
expanding your markets and then what's
like the list of criteria that you look
at and then the second part of that is
of that list of criteria how are you
determining what is
more important over others what is the
most important aspect to help you pick
the one that you decide to move forward
on
are we talking about
completely new genres
of doing new businesses or opportunities
where we talk about expansion of
current ones
well a lot of the companies that i've
been working with have infrastructure
and i've helped them pivot into
industries that didn't even exist yet
like delta 8 delta 10 and other
derivatives and then i've also stepped
in with other people and started setting
up emerging markets that don't aren't
really there yet that are speculative
i'm trying to figure out a way to
well essentially uh when you start
looking into potential wars that are
happening government contracts are going
to come up and there's low-hanging fruit
for individuals to fill those contracts
is one of the emerging industries that
i'm looking at for the next three to six
months and then some of the other
industries is you can go through the uk
into europe to get the stamps of
approval with cannabis products that
then can be distributed all throughout
the eu and i have a distribution network
lined up uh through a guy who owned
swanson health products so let me
download
in a world where arbitrage comes natural
to you
yeah
the thing i would start with is
[ __ ] you actually are interested in
okay
because i think what's happening is what
you're interested in is the arbitrage
i'm a little bit similar to you this way
this is why
i think i really made a big great
decision with vaynerx it wasn't
what i decided to do 12 13 years ago
would have been very different than what
you would have decided because i could
have made a lot more money doing a
hundred thousand other things but i had
incredible self-awareness
and and in hindsight foresight to
understand that
everything i was going to do in
perpetuity would still find
itself doing the thing that i do
which is
really understand marketing of the
second as the arbitrage to make consumer
demand happen for something
you know i think
and and now you know knowing all the
charges i have on my wall like be
friends is just like the logical
thing that happened right and rezzy and
empathy and all these things worked
garyvee the brand it all worked
you know the thing that strikes me andy
is for you to consider
maybe starting a company
that
is
omni and more leveled up similar to what
i did
that is built around your skills but
scales it so that you can then deploy it
against anything and everything
and or
taking a step back and realizing okay
i'm good at
the
science of
figuring it out
why don't i deploy that against a
subject matter that is the single most
interesting thing to me from a
standpoint of it would be my hobby
okay you know you know i think you
because then you could have retention
and you could build something meaningful
over the long term
okay do you see where i'm going
yeah see the thing that i'm kind of at a
crossroads that is money is arbitrary to
me it's i'm more about learning and
experiences throughout my life i've been
blessed with some great people who have
mentored me
and
one of the things that i i want to do
something that actually changes the
world and i don't know how to apply some
of my background yet to do that so i'm
trying to gain as much experience in as
many industries as i can so that when i
come into complex situations i can draw
from my rolodex my experiences
in different contexts
so
is your world
based on being a company that
helps different scenarios or is it you
go to thing to thing and you do deals
within it
that i usually find people through not
to be overly spiritual but
opportunities happen to fall in my path
that i
am capable and no people to fix the
situation or
create the next market
have you created the container that this
talent sits in is there like a company
like is there an andy richards
consultants
um i created a promotional products
company called pledge promo where i
bought out all the partners and now
that's my vehicle that i do things and
it's pledge consulting because i pledge
to my the people i work with that i will
put every ounce of energy into figuring
whatever it is out
yeah i mean okay good i mean i think i
you know it's very similar to what i'm
doing i wanted to get the context of
everything so i could use it in the
future which is why i built vayner and
so i'm a buyer of this
how big is the company is it just you
and and you then it's an army of me
it's just an army of me and friends of
mine that do various things but i get it
i got there's a couple very wealthy and
i'm talking in the billionaire range
that have
acquired my services on retainer which
has funded me to be more philanthropic
through what i decide to do personally
but i just have to at the core figure
out when they have issues
i understand okay is there you know as
far as to answer your original question
now that i understand
uh on complete intuition of what makes
me happy
okay
when you're trying to import and it's a
really interesting answer and i think
you'll understand and i appreciate your
response to it
when you want to do everything in
perpetuity you're not crippled by the
next decision
okay
like
you know that i i don't struggle with
decisions i'm trying to get around to
everything anyway so if we're going to
do denver right now or if we're going to
do you know nfts or if we're going to do
production like
cool it's we're going to get to
everything anyway eventually
yeah
cool
thank you thank you
thank you gary got it
we'll head over to bobby over in
california bobby what you got for gary
gary you you said you've been thinking
about my space so why don't i just say
what you've been thinking about man i
think that a
better more upscale version in this
space than like the infomercial
billboard thing requires you acting like
a publisher not a marketer
can you explain what you mean by that
i can so instead of running the ads
i think you should build a franchise
core
youtube or podcast show
right
and that you should have guests and
educate and give out tons of free advice
create content that on that show that
helps people for not reaching out to you
or your contemporaries the ones that are
good and the ones that are sleazy when
they don't need to because you're giving
them information that will stop them
from like you know it's like the whole i
always thought the best lawyer
brand in the world that if i had that
skill set i would have built the biggest
company because my whole motto would
have been i'm giving you as much free
information as possible so you never
hire us
again it's a very common theme it's what
back to james and joe right julia like
let's like do this is not 4d this was
huge james will tell you i [ __ ] spent
weeks on this i was like guys you know
because they would bring it up they're
like oh my god 4d is going to be cool
and we can use it as a sales i'm like it
is not a sales engine
not a person if anybody leaves that
spent real money and i think a dollar is
really money and leaves like this was
just we got we got we paid to get
pitched
i'm gonna kill you that's literally how
passionate i was about it and i i really
believe humans are animals and they
sense intent
i believe bobby you had a weekly podcast
where the people over time and you could
cut up the content and the whole model
that you know we'll go through and you
know you'll know about i don't know if
you've done that yet or we won't you
know but
i it will work because then you're not a
marketer you don't have to market it
people will find you over time in
perpetuity
right
got it you see where i'm going and by
the way that stuff then you start
chopping up that one hour episode that
30 minute episode and it becomes your
ads on linkedin on facebook like but the
ad is like a quality piece of
information it's not an ad
right it's like a movie trailer instead
of an ad it's just a clip
right
right it is the disproportionate
the reason i've been thinking about you
is it's very obvious to me that in
markets that have some hair on it
that this model is over indexing because
i've been speaking to this model for
quite a while and so i'm receiving a lot
of emails from people that
are very transparent like hey i was a
scammy of the scam in this space and
something you said in this video made me
do this and this happened and this is
what happened or my dad was in this
space and he was like a pioneer in it it
was a little infomercially and i did
this like you said and this app like i
just i think there's something there
there yeah
what so so it's you know i just need to
be like in the back of people's [ __ ]
head when something bad happens to them
and like that's the [ __ ] i need
to call right now right so
how
how
how would you scale that or how would
you build i mean like easy it's the life
i live
yeah literally like and very very easy
it's why i'm trying to give you the
formula right
i
am at the forefront of people what
people think about when marketing
because
rachel and todd like me because i'm
putting out free information that's good
and motivational and tactical and
and i don't know what they or anybody
here first thought when they saw me but
you know after a little while no matter
the most cynical if the other shoe never
drops and there is no mastermind there's
no eight thousand dollar course that
there's no eventually you gotta be like
[ __ ] what i guess this you know and then
you start digging deeper you're like oh
he's got other you know and i that's
what i want for you i want you to be top
of mind because you're providing value
information
you know and you can put out tons of
content you know how
for people to avoid getting sued
you know you know [ __ ] that i don't know
but like if this would stop me in my
tracks for my dad if i'm just scrolling
and says how retailers can stop from
getting sued
i would literally just click that and
said to my dad and be like dad don't mop
the floors during working hours
okay
you know so like you know what i mean
like there's a lot of weight you know
the first thing you're supposed to do
that's right james jab jab jab right
hook is right like but i i think if you
know if i can get you to think that
you're a podcaster not a marketer you'll
be more top of mind
publishing publishers are always more
top of mind than marketers
right when suzy orman's on tv
and jim cramer's on tv people think of
them for financial advice a hell of a
lot more than whoever the [ __ ] showed up
in their google adwords or on the
infomercial in between at two o'clock in
the morning on cnbc
you could now establish that brand on
the internet for no cost
yeah
talk to me does that make sense yeah
totally um talk to me i use the word the
80 20 rule i i think i heard you have a
one percent rule so my [ __ ] bandwidth
is
max right so
just give me some
some some so i got some good thoughts on
that so how i'm spending you know eighty
percent of my time trying to get twenty
percent of my assets how do i spend
more of my time getting 80 of my assets
well first of all you raise your price
one of the things that a lot of people
are confused about
when they're
at a max capacity practitionership
is the need to raise the price
if that's true
you need to raise your price
talk to me about that before i go to the
next part
well i
i don't have a price i'm a contingency
fee so i don't i don't build by the hour
so god it's kind of hard for me to do
resp that's why i wanted i knew you were
pausing and i was like there's something
i need to know got it so you're making a
piece of the action so you're making
you're spending your time deciding if
this is quote unquote worth your time
right okay and so fine comma go back to
the 80 20. you're spending 80 percent of
your time to get
the customers for the 20 of your work
well no i'm spending you know like
80 percent of my time dealing with with
twenty percent of the [ __ ] that i
have to deal with instead of focusing on
what one
the stuff that actually makes me money
respect like what
the lower end cases
um can you hire a lawyer to do that
content developments all that sort of
stuff let's talk about the lower end
cases first because content is easy
uh lower lower cases are you willing
can you hire lawyers to do that or i'm
just farming them out now
and rev sherry right so then has that
problem been solved somewhat yeah
have you considered adding a per
people or no lawyers yeah i'm pretty
built out right now
how many how many lower level lawyers do
you have
uh four
and is it better for you to farm it out
and rev share than it is to add a fifth
or sixth or seventh i sleep better
because that [ __ ] that's a great answer
yeah that i love okay uh talk to me
about the content part that you refer to
next well i got a guy i'm paying you
know a shitload of money a month
four grand
to do what
develop [ __ ] for instagram facebook and
just get it all out there and it's not
working right
not really yeah and do you spend any
media dollars to amplify the four grand
of content no but i i will from time to
time like um higher companies do
targeted campaigns on very niche type
cases
that you know i'm not not like you know
like like
a billboard guy trying to get car crash
cases that's not going to work for me
right but if there's some case that i
know that's out there that nobody else
knows about i'll spend some money on a
targeted campaign for those types of
cases from an scm standpoint yeah
people's intent what they type in and
you show up and because you know it
right long-term right right and is that
effective yes so why don't you do more
of that
well these niche things only come along
and they only niche for so long before
everybody else finds out about them i
understand what about paying more for
them even though more people found out
about it so instead of paying 39 a lead
spending 297.
yeah i'll tell you i'll tell you why i'm
asking these questions because they're
common things that i've seen friends
startups things i'm involved in you know
people get emotion people take so much
pride in finding the niche
that when the niche gets crowded
they actually think it's time this was a
huge problem for me in my 20s
i would know things about wine i was
buying customers for 10 cents it was a
different day back then
and then and then it'd be a dollar
and i'd be like oh [ __ ] everybody
figured out the [ __ ] australian
shiraz thing meanwhile in hindsight
years later i'm like i'm an idiot it was
working for me at a dollar i should have
poured more lighter fluid on it
right thoughts on that well i guess i'm
just sort of i've always been more
organic and i'm i'm just sort of afraid
of spending money
because you have pride in being organic
and by not spending money it makes you
feel less like the others
no it's just sort of it
it
i guess it's just it feels like an
ideology versus an actual business no
i've just thrown some money i've just
thrown some money away i hate doing it
because sometimes it doesn't work and i
you know i spent a hundred thousand
dollars
bobby sometimes sometimes a lot of
things don't sometimes you lose the case
i i think there's something really here
i'll tell you why long tail sem in your
business is a real thing
if you complement it with what i want
you to do which is to do a show
instead of having 4 000 wasted on
content that's probably not effective
turn that 4000 a month into a production
team of two people that has a weekly
podcast for you and then you clot up the
clips from the show and now you're
putting out good content in digital form
and video form complementing the sem i
think you're going to build more of a
brand and then over 24 to 36 months
people are just subconsciously coming to
you and then you really stop spending
ads yeah you had already given some
thought to that like fireside chat with
like really kick-ass lawyers sipping
whiskey talking about shop oh
i'm telling you
that based on everything i've heard from
you and just like the way you your
feelings are it's gonna work for you
more you're wasting 4 000 a month i can
smell it from a million miles away
because i know what that looks like in
social media land and i think you should
convert that into a show that produces
12 pieces of social media content from
each episode the way my content is
produced right
i do stuff and then we chop it
not make it for it
right
okay
how much content
should i be blasting out on a daily
basis
as much as humanly possible
i swear to god this is back to some of
the guys here
on health and fitness you just asked me
how well should i eat and how much
exercise should i do a day
lots
as much as possible now in workout land
there's a little bit of resting and some
other variables not in this one as much
as possible
yeah promise
let's
move on over to robin uh robin
definitely creates a lot of content he's
got some great questions for you gary go
ahead robin
i feel like i never create enough um so
sold my restaurant event space in san
francisco um woke up two weeks later
said [ __ ] i didn't create enough content
about it and and
[Music]
really
throughout my career right like done a
bunch of weird things never really told
the story well so said okay i want to
make that mistake never again and
there's other people making that mistake
too i saw you start talking about that
uh unfortunately after the fact right
but like if my nephew could come in and
uh you know his eyes got big because i
owned an ice cream machine right
incredible stories
so xander media mostly were doing
explainer videos nine people didn't
realize it was an agency until i hired
my second employee because i don't know
anything about agencies until now two
and a half years later this summer's
been incredible we opened up our first
office in the bay
um hired our first full-time designer
after video folks uh are managing a 30k
ad spend on linkedin for the first time
but
there's so many moving pieces of an
agency um and then of course the piece
around personal brand i'm happy to be on
stage i like performing um i don't need
to be right how much to promote xander
media how much to promote myself uh and
then how to build a content machine
around the promotion to to feedback to
the business
um as much as you can as much of you
being on stage and building your
personal brand as you can afford to that
doesn't come at the detriment of the
operations of the business
too many people
don't understand how the world is
actually structured they have this
philosophy that if it's about them
they can't sell their company one day
because they're right they think about
that they think about
well then all our clients won't want any
of my account people they're always
going to want they come up with all the
things that
all of them are secondary to the fact
that a human being is always going to be
a bigger brand machine and builder to
business development and then on the
client side
when they come in you say from second
one
hey kieran you know before we even get
started here
i am robin xander but xander media is
not robin sanders xander media is the
joke of drones intermediates
james you know so you control that when
they come in the pipe and you the human
bring in the most pipe and as far as
building a content team around it
you need a copywriter a media person a
video person and a
design person and that's a lot of people
one person could be all four in the
beginning like it was for me eventually
it's four different people and those
become managing resources and that
becomes a game of you leaving money on
the table
from the distributions of the profits of
the business and pouring it back into
the business right and i'm building this
for the rest of my life because i'm
going to do other things right
so no desire to sell uh no desire to
leave this behind i'm still delivering
all of our work and so i think in some
way uh i'm afraid of letting go of the
reins of like client facing control
yeah i think that's that immediately has
to be step one
step one two three four five six seven
is
who is going to be the account person
that you trust if you go into a tree for
19 months
that is your business will not scale
in any shape or form without that if
you're the deliverer of the client work
right yeah right now we're we're trying
to decide between rpg content personal
brand content and xander media client
work right and and because i'm the
limiting factor correct
yeah
you the account person on xander media
is everything
cool
um
where to go niche so like most of our
money in the last two and a half years
has been video production but we're i i
can do other things right the team is
starting to get interested in like how
do we manage ad spend or we're gonna
produce some squarespace websites for a
client um where to go niche at this
stage right if the goal is long long
long term the rest of my life but if you
lose your life then much like the
earlier thing to andy you can go
anywhere and i think going to where
current employees interests are passions
and skill sets is always a good idea
cool
right because when you're showing them
that you're supporting their decision
they're bought in emotionally and that
builds a great culture yeah yeah
which brought me here right i mean i i
for five years now run a conference on
future work hr that cloud spoke out et
cetera so like culture i feel like we've
got really going well and and will
continue to go well
but then how to scale essentially scale
myself
by not being scared
yeah
you know my number one strength
is
that it
when not if when james or see me james
can speak to this maybe now or when i
leave
when james orsini calls me and tells me
we've lost a client the amount of energy
and time spent on that is shockingly low
i'm almost disinterested in learning
from it
whereas as you can and that you're gonna
have to figure out that year if you're
gonna scale you're gonna hire karen
or johnny they're gonna be the account
person and inevitably as you start to
trust them
inevitably one day they're gonna call
you and say we just lost the blank blank
account
and you have to become accountable that
you hired that person
who lost the account
not lose your mind and get fearful
any recommendations on cash flow right
like that feels like such a
i mean i'm paying for it on the back of
my own savings from the sale of the
restaurant like never had a line of
credit anything like that no debt
um no investors
uh make more money than you use
and don't [ __ ] it up so much that i then
go out of business
yeah i think people get caught on cash
flow when they're not in tune with their
actual business
okay the fact that you even ask that is
the follow-up questions already made me
halfway confident
you know when i get you know james
probably remembers this too like when i
bring in grown-ups to companies because
of my casualness and my true
entrepreneurship and pure offense i'm
empathetic that people around me
focus on
all those things and i just always
remind
them occasionally of like hey
been in business every day i have been
the person responsible for the pna for
the last 25 years of my life with a
weekly or bi-weekly you know paycheck
that i have to make for everybody and
for the first 12 years of my career i
had no credit line
so you know i know how to make payroll
and so that's just being in tune with
your business
cool
i've seen
so many trends right looking at at v
friends looking at nfts like i remember
google in 2000 before it went public um
what would you do if you were starting
an agency now towards sort of web 3.0
and whatever comes next or should i just
not bother and should i because 100 of
my sales is me on calls with people
right like 100 of the business is
organic growth through one-on-one
conversations and relationships
when i think about we're not video is is
present but it's not necessarily the
only thing in the future would you focus
on future or start where i am right now
i think you would based on you it's
similar to what i did i think you have
to build around your interests and
skills
so if you're actually interested and
feel like you have intuitive skills to
do web3 strategy then do it
you know we built the nft because i
thought i could do it right
because i knew it because i put in the
six nine months before that point that
made me feel confident that i could but
play in the places that i know the best
or that my team knows the best right
correct
or that you're most
intrigued by and you actually put in the
work and then you do it right to your
point and it's the right observation
everything went perfect storm for me
with nft land because it's all my life's
work
you know but
uh ai
i believe in heavily but i don't stand
it up as a main thing here
but i invest in it so i can keep it
close to me
and then eventually
you see
right i care about acrobatics and circus
so like keep creating content about
handstands and eventually cirque du
soleil will come back around again
yeah
or or what does circus culture mean to
every brand
that's what you can get really
interesting from a strategy standpoint
cool
cool
thank you uh welcome let's move along we
got to get to lee over in denver lee uh
take your stuff off mute and then uh
thank you
this has been this has been so great i
mean
tons of different variety in the
businesses and
things that you can
pick up from everybody's rightly that's
why we love this format like even though
the businesses are different you know i
always answer with hoping that there's
collateral impact on everybody who's
listening as well and i think that's why
this session it works great all my notes
have nothing to do with my business but
are totally applicable so
it's good uh okay so
uh
actually today we we launched a product
uh gary our our business is kind of
split into two
uh sections of executive intelligence
delivery one of them is delivering truth
to power
that's sort of the executive side we
deliver executives information that they
don't have time or they don't have
access to
the new product is around the notion
that credibility is everything so
uh this product uh takes
uh existing executive thought leadership
content
uh we run through our ai and then it is
validated by third-party
media and influencer stories
that our ai filters out
uh selects and then packages up to an
email that's sent to
prospects
employees i understand yeah so um
i i'm gonna spend some time on the
thought leadership topic we touched on
it a little bit in the media section
what do you think the future of thought
leadership is in the b2b space
um a more well-rounded conversation
around emotional intelligence
can you elaborate on that a little bit
i think
hard information is a commodity
and i think you're going to see
a lot of the world
lean into
conversations that look more like
therapy
than look like training manuals
that what people are going to start
gravitating have
what i tend to do is not predict has
already happened
in the b2b space
i think you're going to get
conversations that speak to
what it really takes to build out a
sales team in 2023 yeah
which is a hell of a lot more about
empathy and
accountability and
curiosity and words that are just like
never thrown around in b2b business
world and i think that is where thought
leadership is absolutely going
and do you think that that plays the
same at the level of
a senior executive at
you know i do let me let me tell you why
i no matter what you were about to say
yes and let me tell you why
i believe
in
that
big business and business and mid-sized
business
is
going to continue to be affected
culturally
like
they have been around
movements like
metoo and racism and we are having
difficult and important conversations in
our society that are bleeding into the
business world
and i believe that
that the
youth movement
of their thoughts about this that there
will be resistance at the upper level
because we a lot of people think it's
over coddling and entitlement and
there's absolutely nuances and truth
into that
but i think the evidence will be
overwhelming
that
healthy
cultures are going to outpace
everybody in business results
and more importantly my perspective is
that i come from an angle where
this isn't about
altruism this is about actually winning
the game
and i think you're starting to see a
convergence of
alpha
ambition i call it honey empire right
yeah of course
i mean and i i it's so black and white
to me obviously i'm so in tune with it
but
it is absolutely i'm blown away
by
whom is reaching out to me quietly
wanting to learn more about some of
these things
and their
characters that i thought would probably
retire before they would care and it
would be the person that would take over
i i just think it's mounting and it's
mounting quickly and i think the reason
it lands
is because it's gonna play out on the
field
like you know empathy isn't a nice to
have this isn't about being nice it's
not candy at the counter this is not a
foosball table
in the middle of the office it's not a
tactic it's actually going to be black
and white for people sooner than later
and i think it's absolutely where things
are going and this is not
and and this is
a actual answer observation this is not
something i i'll be very frank with you
i care so much about the empire part
as a competitor on the field
that
i have no horse in this race i just
react to what i see
right okay so a follow-up to that
question again this
uh
software which we think is sort of the
first thought leadership
enhancement software that's out there
you take three paragraphs of your
content you upload it rai reads it and
finds content that agrees with or aligns
with that topic it sounds to me like
we have to play a part in coaching the
exec for that that concept to be its
most effective and by the way we're
seeing like 60 70 engagement rates off
of test customers um
four to ten times what you get off of a
blog post
yeah so clearly the two variables in
that is the training of
the
input
yep
and well
you just hit the nail on the head the
training of the input is actually more
important than the training of the ai of
course the training of the ai is a
commodity over time
over time i have to hold on to it
non-commoditized for a little 100 100
but the but that is the commodity over
time
the what is not a commodity in that is
and i i am very fascinated on how
ai because i'm spending a lot of time on
it and i'm very aware of how nascent it
is compared to the hyperbole and your
point was well taken it's a marketing
term
there the two variables of you building
a monster are the training of the input
and the ability to create
uh ai that is extremely strong at
tonality context nuance and slang
so what would you tell an executive
and we're selling this to verizon aeon
you know large you know panasonic varys
so on and so forth
and thought leadership seems to have
struck a nerve
with executives coming out of the
pandemic we're still trying to figure
that out
what would you coach an executive how
would you coach an executive if they
were buying from us
and we're and and the input is every
single week you give i got here i got it
hey hey ceo
conservative old school ceo
build a committee of 12
editors for the input i want you to give
me a mix of your six to 12 key
executives who all hit the spectrum of
the hard and the soft so that the
collective
content is well-rounded
fantastic okay one last question uh do
you mind james do i have some another
okay great
um
the last decade has
brought to the forefront the concept of
information overload and media fatigue
that bleeds into mental health yes
there's a little bit of paradox going on
here where we're trying to find
eyeballs of individuals
who are
feeling the impact of information
overload and media fatigue
and using media to reach them
that's that's easy that's no different
than going back to jonathan
who i'm sure
or or andy when he realized executives
weren't eating well
you know i think we all can agree
that if you're a poor eater for two
decades
and then you've decided to get your [ __ ]
together
that the notion of cutting everything
all at once and demonizing any escapism
is a bad idea
you know i think i you know i think all
of us even the healthiest eater that's
raising a healthy family if you over
demonize a random cupcake once at a blue
moon you're actually doing a detriment i
would argue lee that you're building the
random cupcake
no humans will always want information
i love that we might use that somewhere
this is what you're here for uh you know
that that's exactly right um final final
question um
we have spent a lot of time debating
whether or not the feed
user interface is a broken way for
humans to consume content if they think
i've got a really good answer for this
one and
over or
if you gave me the option of getting it
in feed getting it in text form or
getting an email form or getting in
voice recording form i would be very
happy and so when you're cuss all of
your customers don't make the decision
for the customer give them the options
uh that actually is and i think that's a
great you know piece of advice for
everybody on the call is that the the
feed uh in in terms of certain
demographics may be
wilting somewhat because it's you know
this never-ending thing is connected to
other problems that we're dealing with
including
fatigue and inflammation overload in the
workplace that re you know in some cases
that reduces productivity so we're
trying to i mean humans humans
humans
are
the issue with productivity
yeah
you know like
to your point i mean like you know a
feed versus a book versus a tv show
versus a video
if your intent is to not be productive
you won't be productive i don't think
you worry about the mechanics i just
think you just give people options and
you call it a day
good advice
you got it okay let's move on thank you
very much
rachel and todd take yourself off mute
guys
hi hi
thanks again for your time i feel like
we had a lot and i do
and my head is like constantly spinning
with a lot um but that's really um you
know what drives this question i think
that we're two people like with
moving parts and we need help
prioritizing like not only just time
management but allocating dollars like
yeah we're making the money we have an
average of 30 000 per se you know per
month in sales we have we're up to date
per
uh what is it 300 000 to date right for
sale let's start with let me help you
right away because this [ __ ] talk
about something i know
you have to make pretend the store
doesn't exist
that's hard when i have to run it
good news i did this and i ran a store
for 15 hours a day seven days a week for
13 years
so so you it's a little bit different
let me say it again you have to make
pretend the store doesn't exist what did
that what does that mean
it means that every minute you spend on
this store
is
is a questionable minute because it's
not scalable by any stretch of the
imagination compared to your dot com
infrastructure
it doesn't mean you don't spend time on
it
it means that you consciously look at
each other and say are we giving eighty
percent of our
energy to the dot com or are we giving
you and you've and your 20 has to be
good enough for the store
what does that mean that means all of a
sudden very quickly you say wait a
minute we're going to hire a manager for
the store
that's a young kid
at a you know that's really going to
dominate and they're out there i've
lived my whole life in this they're
absolutely out there people don't think
they're out there
it's hard people get paid more to stay
home all that shit's about to go away
like you you've got to really understand
that
for you to build the best possible
business you have to build up the dot
you have to put crazy energy on your
best work on the dot com because the
comparisons aren't even close to
building an actually
bigger business it's not even close
like i feel like we just can't get ahead
no matter how much money we're making
we're also spending right on what on
product on inventory on marketing on
supplies on staffing on indonesia
somebody to clean up our images so
everything is cookie cutter and looks
the part on the website so it's
professional so one of the things is
my dad had the same problem when i came
to his business and so the first thing i
did was made much higher margin product
so let's start there
if you were able to create a brand that
is your private label that has some
juice to it
all of a sudden you can charge 60 for a
t-shirt instead of 12.
so one of one of the ways to get ahead
in a retail business in your category
is to create a low-cost item around a
brand that you own
okay
because one of your biggest issues is
the margin structure that you play with
it
and as you know there's only so much you
can get away with on a piece compared to
the competitive market space right
it's not like you're like oh thanks gary
you're a genius and go mark up
everything double the price the problem
is nobody's gonna buy it
right you could google search anything
and price match and price count but what
i think you need to think about
is creating your kirkland
the number one thing i would do if i was
the third new partner you know
kirkland is costco's private label
you need a kirkland
if you build a kirkland it will change
your business
okay i just need to figure out what that
kirkland is
yes but you have to understand this is
like exciting for me because it really
matters yeah like if you nail that it
changes everything because if you're
actually hit pay dirt on that
then your your margins in a totally
different place
just feel like so much about the retail
store again it's like customer service
you don't walk into a store there's
nowhere to be seen like when you walk
into our store we're there we care like
we're fully
in everything that is like matters to
you as a child as the parent i love it
it's great you don't get that anymore
but like i don't want to lose sight of
that and if i'm not there i'm watching
my employee as we speak i'm like are you
helping that customer
i think i think you have to something
that i really struggled with my dad on
this issue nobody cared about customers
more than both of us
you don't die on one interaction
you don't
so first you have to take that insanity
out of your soul
don't be scared of a random yelp review
like get get you are so fear-based with
that statement it's crazy
yeah
i mean because it can make or break you
in this like it feels like yeah i know
but it feels like it can well that's
very nice a lot of things feel
that are true
people feel all sorts of things that are
wrong that's why people go to jail
you know like like you know you but
rachel's really important because if you
have that framework you lose perspective
is reality
if you believe that to be true
you've got no shot there's a reason
you're in a hamster wheel
you're suffocated by non-scalable
ideology
well i mean that brings me to you know i
know you're crunched for time but like i
deal with have you heard of denny's i'm
sure everybody's heard of denny's they
have nine locations so we're less than
five miles away from denny's and denny's
loves loves to go after my vendors and
tell my vendors not to sell to me he has
bullied his way to the shop for 20 years
he is who he is he hasn't bullied
i might be nicer than this person but
when i was buying lots of wine from
somebody i had no interest in them
selling to one random store in manalapan
a wine that could hurt my margin
okay so fair so then what do you do when
you're that one mama and pop shop that
is strong you know like
yeah but this is business nobody gives a
[ __ ] about your feelings
i
think honestly like that's very nice
like don't open a [ __ ] store then if
you're like you know what i mean like on
some real [ __ ] do not play that
eliminate that immediately
i'm being serious find other vendors
i have to run we'll talk more i'll get
you five more minutes but we you have to
build a brand that nobody else can buy
anywhere else
if you're a retail store in
2021 2022 and you don't have a private
label that is the number one thing you
focus on you will never win
cheers bye everyone
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this
is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon